[Music]
the beach is not a very safe anyone can
relate to feeling uncomfortable on the
beach men women queer otherwise and it's
also a very gendered space like the
moment you put your toes in the sand you
know it and you feel it and you know
that you have to kind of pick one side
of the spectrum either you're more on
the masculine side or you're more on the
feminine side what does that do for
everyone that doesn't exist on one clear
side or the others I am Ari Fitz and I
run a fashion project called palm voyage
in so many ways aims to tackle the way
that we see beauty and the way that we
see masculinity and femininity a couple
years ago I really started to balance my
own masculinity and femininity and I
felt really good and I felt like myself
I wanted to help other people get there
- to me getting dressed in the morning
is kind of like putting on my suit of
armor as a queer person as a woman as a
person of color I feel like there are so
many things in this world that wants to
silence us silence me minimize me and
minimize my experience in this world
what we choose to wear signifies that we
are here we are present and we're not
going to be silent we're not going
anywhere so the process I'm working on
is a really dope super hot lookbook that
features all things swimwear for those
who don't exist on the hyper masculine
side of the hyper feminine side like
myself because I know what it feels like
to step out on the beach and not feel
confident
we have to get create we have to find
items that most of the time you wouldn't
really think are like swimwear or
beachwear pieces and we have to make
them ours
when vests also body suits and then from
there just accessorize it's a feat it's
meant to be fun it's meant to be light
it's summer the stress and the trauma
that people experience when they go
through a beach is just like it's so
unnecessary the more I can do to just
get it out of the way and make the beach
fun again that means that my job is on
do you boo just rock it just make sure
you're like rocking it with like you
know some confidence and you got it
[Music]